[Music]
people often ask me just how dire I
think the state of free speech in
America really is in the last two weeks
I've spoken at several college campuses
in California Arizona and Texas as well
as attended a conference in Dallas
primarily focused on free speech from an
academic perspective I spoke to dozens
of professors who feel that the ability
to truly exchange ideas or even to
express unpopular opinions on their
campus is at a perilous crossroad the
University of Berkeley wants the home
for the free speech movement in this
country quite literally went up in
flames when Miley innopolis spoke there
people with fairly moderate opinions
like professor Jordan peterson and
historian charles murray are shouted
down by self righteous students on
college campuses all the time now and
Coulter was first barred by Berkeley and
then told she could only speak on a day
when students weren't actually having
class on campus these safe spaces and
trigger warnings concept designed to
protect feelings instead of dealing with
facts coupled with constant smearing of
any intellectual opponent as racist or
bigoted has birthed a generation who are
increasingly intolerant of tolerance I
should also be clear here it really is
one side who's being far more intolerant
on campuses these days just think for a
second if any college campus invited a
far-left Marxist or communist who wanted
to end capitalism and ultimately destroy
the United States there would be
virtually no outcry the Marxist and
communists would have their event with
maybe a couple curious people
challenging their ideas in the Q&A and
that would be it the absolute reverse is
happening all over the country when a
conservative or any non leftist speaker
are invited to college campuses ben
shapiro a friend and former guest of the
rubin report has been banned from DePaul
for sharing his brand a pretty
mainstream conservative thought Ann
taifa the self-proclaimed anti-fascist
who actually used fascist tactics to
silence their opponents and who also
happen to dress like Cobras soldier
from GI Joe issued a statement and
threatened to protest Portland State
University when Christina Hoff Sommers
Peter Bogosian and I spoke there
apparently at the last second they found
something more anti-gay and more
anti-woman right before we started so
they move their protest somewhere else
and of course as I always say and will
continue to say you have every right to
protest and use your speech to counter
someone else's speech what you don't
have is a right to silence someone by
using violence or intimidation this is
why I talk so much about self-censorship
and the chill effect around free speech
violence not only silences the speakers
of today but in essence it silences the
speakers of tomorrow who will quiet
themselves instead of dealing with the
protests and smears and everything else
that comes with being someone who thinks
outside of the group what's being stolen
from these college students is the
ability to learn how to think about
complex issues while in university so
that they can be equipped to engage with
a diverse set of ideas in the real world
and that diversity diversity of thought
is far more important than diversity of
immutable characteristics be it race
religion or sexuality last week I spoke
at the University of Arizona with my
friend and former guest Michael Shermer
it turned out that there was a trans
Holocaust denier in the crowd yes
apparently trans Holocaust deniers do
exist not only did we not silence her
but we opened up the floor for her to
ask us the first question when we did
the Q&A Michael the editor-in-chief of
skeptic magazine who specializes in
debunking conspiracy theories is an
expert in debunking Holocaust denial
myths and he answered her questions
clearly and with facts the students in
the room didn't attack her or kick her
out
despite her abhorrent beliefs it was
actually a beautiful moment which shows
why free speech is so important we
exercise our right to talk openly at a
public event which anyone was welcome to
join she then shared her ideas which
then we countered with better ideas
while I suspect Michael didn't change
her
mind on holocaust denial we put our
principles of free expression to the
test this open discussion with a wide
array of opinions is how you expand
knowledge and figure out what you
believe not by silencing shaming and
defaming your ideological opponent sadly
the true tolerance that we experienced
in that room that night is an increasing
rarity on college campuses these days I
know I don't have to sell you guys on
the lunacy that's happening at college
campuses you see it every day with the
language police telling people what
pronouns to use on the endless stream of
insane stories coming from America's
campuses showing how intolerant the
so-called tolerant side has become what
I'd like to focus on here for a second
is the creeping groupthink and
obfuscation around free thought and free
speech that is now creeping up into the
political s lon just this week you may
have seen new Democratic National
Committee Chairman Tom Perez say that
the DNC won't back any politicians who
are pro-choice well I have no problem
with the party having a set of beliefs
as a guideline for its policies that's
the whole point of a party this type of
intolerance to other ideas even if
they're incredibly difficult topics like
abortion set a terrible precedent for
the exchange of ideas in a pluralistic
society this specific event isn't a
direct threat to free speech but it does
go to the heart of how intolerance by
the left is driving otherwise liberal
people to the center and even to the
right or as the left calls it the
neo-nazi all right white supremacist
far-right the more egregious assault on
free speech in the last couple days
however was from the former head of the
DNC and one-time presidential candidate
Howard Dean Dean is a progressive who at
this point really sums up why this
ideology is not truly for progression of
freedom and liberalism but for
regression of them after hearing that
Ann Coulter was going to be banned from
Berkeley Dean claim that Coulter's hate
speech was not protected by the First
Amendment
well actually Howard it is a hundred
percent absolutely full stop
first off Dean uses the amorphous term
hate speech which sounds like something
but doesn't actually exist yes you can't
call for direct violence to a person or
a group that's a criminal offense but
you are allowed to say hateful and mean
things that's the very part of free
speech that we have to protect because
the definition of hate speech will just
keep expanding until it includes any
speech that fears ever so slightly away
from group think beyond Dean's confusion
about hate speech he also apparently
doesn't know what the First Amendment
actually is as I know you know the First
Amendment is about prohibiting the
government from making any laws
prohibiting free speech it has
absolutely nothing to do with the speech
of a private person or hate speech or
university d platforming a speaker if
you truly care about minorities college
Republicans I hate to tell you are a
minority at most universities and they
deserve to be heard from just like
anyone else who has been offered a
platform
sadly Dean is a progressive thought
leader while he seemingly has no idea
about the very Constitution our
political leaders are supposed to defend
with this in mind I still absolutely
believe the best way to beat the violent
tactics of an tyfa or the intellectually
challenged ideas of howard dean is to
counter them with better ideas
we shouldn't stoop to their level of
violence or try to take away their free
speech we should teach the ideas of
liberty freedom and true liberalism yes
they'll only scream louder than us or
act more hysterically but I believe our
game is a long one and our better ideas
will win if we actually put them into
practice with this in mind we're
continuing our partnership with learn
liberty this week and joining me is
Brandon Turner a professor of political
science at George Mason University
he's an expert in political theory with
extensive knowledge of the writings of
everyone from John Stuart Mill to Karl
Marx we're going to explore political
thinkers from all across the map to see
which ideas stand the test of time right
or left Democrat or Republican male or
female gay or straight everything
issues starts with our ability to
discuss it and figure out what we
believe if we can unite against the
forces that will silence us we may find
allies in places we never thought we
would
[Music]
you